hello my name is amar bastu
and i'm a scientific advisor at
bioelectronica i'm also a professor at
wayne state university
and uh i'm excited to tell you about
antibody discovery
using computer vision single cell
sorting
and i first want to start by thanking
lab roots
for the opportunity to speak at this
virtual conference it's a great
opportunity
to share information not just only about
the hyper cell system that i'm going to
be talking about
but also the more general
concepts in antibody discovery and
single cell sorting
this is an exciting new method to
identify clones in a population
that secretes large amount of antibodies
then this can enable the rapid screening
of immune cells hybridomas and cell
lines
and save pharmaceutical companies
significant money in the quest for
the development of monoclonal antibodies
this work is a collaboration of many
folks
at bioelectronica including our ceo
jonathan hall
and so i'm presenting this work on
behalf of all of them
so thanks in advance to the entire team
all right so we'll start with the
learning objectives and these are
slightly modified
from what is on the website to follow
this progression of logic we
want to start by talking about the role
of single cell screening in antibody
discovery
workflows in pharmaceutical research so
we'll learn a little bit about
how typical antibody discovery processes
work and how single cell
screening can fit into that the next
objective is to understand
basic concepts in single cell screening
which which is namely the partitioning
of cells into small containers
i will compare different methods of
single cell screening and i think that
will be more or less the educational
part of the talk understanding these
the first three bullet points is just
understanding the lay of the land if you
will
and learning objectives four and five
relate specifically to the
bioelectronica hyper-cell system
so we have some unique ways of doing
single cell screening
so we will be talking about how
hypercell uses clustering
assays lensless imaging and computer
vision
to perform single cell antibody
secretion assays
and then finally we'll talk a little bit
about how the hypercell system performs
uh single cell sorting
okay so let's start with the antibody
discovery workflow
so this is a classic needle in a
haystack problem where high throughput
instruments can actually help
but let's back up for a second so
this is the process of antibody
discovery is a sticky
challenge in pharmaceutical research
the objective of the pharmaceutical
workflows is to establish
cell lines that produce a monoclonal
antibody of interest
and the market for monoclonal antibodies
has grown to beyond 100 billion dollars
per year
as of 2019 it's expected to probably be
even more now
uh considering the intense interest in
antibodies for
things like infectious disease or just
fundamental research and so on
so the goal of the pharmaceutical
company is to get these antibodies out
as quickly
as possible to develop these monoclonal
antibodies
so i'm going to talk about the hybridoma
workflow here but you can
extend it out to other types of
workflows as well so
it begins a conventional workflow begins
when a mouse is immunized
with an antigen of interest and this
will produce an immune response
against that antigen a typical immune
system might produce
more than a billion different
antibodies a repertoire of antibodies
that are
presented on the surface of b cells
these b cells can be harvested uh from
the mouse
spleen now as many of you may know like
one of the
issues with b cells is that they don't
have they don't they don't survive very
well
outside outside the body so not
particularly robust cells
and if you're trying to do a single cell
assays
or you know some type of screening on
these cells which requires a long
culture periods
you won't get very varied necessarily if
you use b cells alone
so the hybridoma technology which has
been around since 1975
is where the b cells are fused with
myeloma cells
and they refuse to form hybridomas
now this technology has come a long way
and it's sort of the mainstay in a lot
of antibody discovery workflows
but one of the issues with hybridoma is
the low efficiency
so the b cells have to survive the
fusion
with the myeloma cells number one
number two they have to be immortalized
and number three they have to continue
secreting the antibody of interest so
there's three things that have to
continue
happening after the electrofusion
process and
you know it varies uh depending on what
process but
a typical number might be one in five
thousand
of these hybridomas are one in five
thousand of the b
cells become functional
hybridomas that are secreting the
antibody of interest
so this low efficiency is one of the
issues now
the other issue then becomes the
screening period
so typically each round of screening so
the goal in screening
is to look at each one of these
hybridomas
and determine if it is secreting an
antibody
that is a counter to this antigen
each round of screening it takes about
two or three weeks
and the cell screening process requires
many rounds of screening
so the cell screening process can take
several months and this is one of the
most expensive
and time-consuming steps in the lead
discovery
workflow typical steps that are involved
in the cell screening include the the
culture of the cells
screening them for antibody secretions
and then performing single cell cloning
the single cells cloning process
requires multiple steps of culture
at a limiting dilution so you start out
with pools and then eventually you
decrease the concentration of the pools
to the point where in
you are in the poisson regime where each
microwell plate might have
a single cell or no cells so that
multi-step
process to get single cell clones takes
a very long time so
in addition to the cell screening once
the hits have been found
then you have to perform a follow-up
screening
you may want to sequence the the cells
that are secreting the antibody of
interest
and in one example those types of those
sequences can be
incorporated into vectors which are
transfected into
cell lines to establish the cell lines
that produce
the monoclonal antibody of interest so
there's a scale-up process here
as well so i've left a lot of the
details out intentionally to keep the
focus on the
cell screening portion so at two to
three weeks
per round and again several months of
work this is a rate limiting step
in in the workflow so where single cell
technology can really play a
an excellent role is uh
by offering a secretion screening
process
that can be done in one or two days
compared to uh several months and so the
the benefits of this is obvious in terms
of cost and time
uh you can go directly into the
follow-up screening so the single cell
screening process works by
looking at each one of these hybridoma
cells and evaluating
whether it's secreting the antibody of
interest
and then pulling those cells out very
much like a cell sorting mechanism
now what's even more exciting than uh
this is the possibility of
screening b cells directly so since
these instruments can screen
within one or two days you're within the
you're within the window
where you could actually screen b cells
before they
you know while they still remain viable
the the potential to screen b cells
directly is very exciting because now
you don't lose
you know 99.9 percent of the
uh the diversity of antibodies that are
produced by the b cells in
you know due to the poor efficiency of
the hybridoma process
so the ability to screen cell b cells
directly is quite exciting
so the typical goal of these instruments
is to screen uh more than
uh one million cells like hybridomas b
cells and cho cells and collect
the top 100 to 200 secretors
this slide just shows a quick summary of
the three different applications as i
mentioned with hybridoma screening
you challenge a mouse with an antigen
you harvest
the b cells from the spleen fuse them
with myeloma cells
and this is what would go into the
screening instrument
so this is the cells would be combined
with the detection reagents
and these detection reagents and the the
sample would then be put into the
uh hypercell instrument or something
like that you'd screen 0.1 to 10 million
cells collect the top 100 to 200
secretors
and then after sample recovery you would
have your positive
hybridoma clones that are you know for
the desired monoclonal antibody
production the second application would
be a direct b cell screening
and this is where the b cells are
combined with the reagents they go into
the reagent prep and into the instrument
and in this case you have positive b
cell clones that are
isolated in the instrument and then the
third application would be that for that
step of
cell line development you know after you
transfect the cell for example
you want to determine whether that cell
has been transfected properly and is
secreting the
the uh protein or antibody of interest
so this type of
single cell screening can be used for
cell line development as well this is
where the cells of interest are put into
the system and out you get
the um the positive cell clones with the
with the correct targets
so uh let's go let's back up for a
second and since this is an educational
talk it's worth
worth the time to talk a little bit
about the concept of partitioning single
cells
so the concept of that quote unquote
digital assays or single cell assays
happens when you have more partitions
than you have cells
so imagine that you have a bunch of
cells in a test tube and those cells are
evenly dispersed
you create a bunch of very very small
partitions
and the cells are evenly distributed
throughout those partitions
so statistically random spacing between
the cells
okay if the number of partitions exceeds
the number of cells
then this lambda value that you see here
at the top is going to be less than one
and that's when you're in well within
the poisson regime
where many of the partitions are going
to be empty shown in red
and some of them will have one or more
cells
if you choose a lambda of 0.1 the
majority 90
will be empty and about 10 will have a
single cell
very very few will have more than one
cell if you choose lambda equals one
you can see in this graph here that the
um the distribution changes a little bit
it'll be just
under forty percent for zero and one
cells and then
um you know there's also the possibility
of having two three four
uh cells in the partitions and and uh so
on with lambda equals three
um one of the key messages here is
having more partitions
allows you to analyze more cells okay
in order to keep the lambda low if you
want to screen a number of a lot of
cells you have to have a lot of
partitions
so there's an advantage to having more
partitions and a few examples of
where many partitions it has helped
in the so-called digital assays which
are not only limited to cells but you
can think about things like digital pcr
which is for quantifying nucleic acids
digital elisa
for quantifying proteins
single cell transcriptomics like
techniques like drop seek
where you you perform single cell
screening um
single cell sequencing i'm sorry and
then the one that we're going to be
talking about today is single cell
secretion assays
so first i just want to mention quickly
about the concept of polydispersity
this question often comes up is that
well if your partitions are not
equal to each other if they don't have
the same volume how do you handle
um you know how do you perform any type
of quantitation
and without getting into all the details
of this i just want to highlight the
main point here
is that if one can
measure the volume of every single pod
every single partition
then the accuracy of quantitation
is actually the same as a mono-dispersed
population
and so this slide shows some monte carlo
simulations that we've done
of that we've compared our method which
is in green
to the blue line here which represents
monodispersed partitions i'm talking
specifically about
the charts on the on the upper right
side here
so if you have a lambda on the x-axis
and your measur
and your your measured lambda on the
y-axis you would like to see
a a line with a slope of one and so you
can see that the bioelectronic
polydisperse model basically follows
that line so it's
as as accurate as having monitors first
partitions provided that you can measure
the volume of each partition
so this is where computer vision comes
in because we can with computer vision
we can actually
use a camera and algorithms to actually
measure the volume of every single
pod that comes through
all right so this slide shows
a variety of single cell assays and
i've shown this because you know as the
educational portion of the talk
i think the audience will find
interesting is that there are many many
different types of single cell assets
that have been developed
this is just a sampling of them that is
actually from
2017 a review paper i wrote at that time
there are many many more even now at
this point um
you know four years later so um
just as to establish some kind of basis
uh i'll give you some examples um you
can look at intracellular gene
expression part a here
this is where a single cell is
expressing an enzyme in the in the
intracellular environment you can use
fluorogenic substrates to measure the
activity of the enzyme
b suppose the cell secretes the enzyme
into the partition around it again you
can use a fluorogenic substrate to
quantify
the amount or activity of the secreted
enzyme
part c is where you have an enzyme label
that's attached to cell surface
biomarkers
again with the fluorogenic substrate
this technique would be used to quantify
cell surface biomarkers
part d is where you have service display
enzymes again with fluorogenic
substrates to quantify the amount
and activity of the enzyme part e
is where you're using um fret assay
with or i'm sorry fluorogenic substrate
assay to measure
the um uh the metabolism of the cell
using oxidase and peroxidase enzymes you
can look at single cell metabolism
you can look at live dead aces for
cytotoxicity screening part
f by staining the cells within
the partition either you know green or
red depending on live or dead
part g as many of you heard about it
drop seek or single cell transcriptomics
is where a cell is co-encapsulated with
dna barcoded
mrna capture beads so when the cell is
lice the mrna transcripts
bind to the bead and the bead actually
has a specific
barcode that links this drop
i'm sorry that links the bead to the
cell
after this is this process is done you
can pull all the partitions together
you can run them through a single
sequencing run and so the dna barcode of
beads will
allow you to see the transcripts of
thousands of cells at any given time
part h is where you can use a single
cell screening techniques for looking at
the quantity of bacteria
okay so let's talk a little bit about
bioelectronica single cell secretion
assays
i mentioned that we are using a
non-fluorescent mechanism
so let's just talk about that a little
bit we have a proprietary bead-based
reagent chemistry
which clusters in the presence of a
particular
antibody so a secreting a pod that
contains a secreting cell a hit
would have a cluster of beads whereas
empty pods or non-secreting cells
would have the beads dispersed evenly
throughout the pods
so then we would collect the hits and we
would
you know not collect the empty pods or
non-secreting cells
so this is a non-fluorescent clustering
mechanism that's compatible with
lensless computer vision
and i'll talk about that in just a
second so the advantages of having a
non-fluorescent assay you avoid things
like photobleaching you avoid
a certain type of reagents that could be
toxic to cells or
reagents which are expensive to develop
uh bead-based assay chemistries are you
know they've
um they're a fairly robust method of
performing assays
uh they're also compatible with
bioelectronic cell growth media
the detection reagents can be customized
for hybridomas and b
cells that are based on a specific
epitope
and they can also be used to detect
activated t cells based on the
specific kind of secretion
so on the left here you'll see an
immunoglobulin assay a negative control
and a positive control
in this case all the pods have um
a physiologically relevant level of igg
in them in the positive control
negative control of course has no igg in
the negative control you can see the
beads dispersed evenly throughout the
pod
as i mentioned in the positive control
you can see clusters being formed
you can take this one step further to a
single cell secretion assay
so this is where single cells are
encapsulated you know in the poisson
regime like i mentioned earlier
pre-incubation you can see the beads are
evenly dispersed throughout
so this is where the cells have not had
enough time to
obtain a sufficient concentration of
antibody
to secrete a sufficient amount of
antibody into the pods
for them to be detected post incubation
you can clearly see the difference
with the red circles that these uh
certain
pods have single cells in them and those
cells are
creating these clusters through their
antibody secretions
so the hypercell system takes this
bead-based chemistry
and it performs a sorting essentially so
you have the secreting cells which
secreting the pods that contain
secreting cells which are considered a
hit
you have the empty pods and the
non-secreting cells
secreting cells are are directed to the
hip
collect outlet using a proprietary
electrofluidic sorter
with integrated electrodes that are
triggered by computer vision
and the empty pods and non-secreting
cells go into the waste
out collect passively so some of the
highlights of the hypercell system is
that it performs gentle sorting with low
shear rates and this can
help with cell viability i'll talk about
why that's the case
and so it would have the ability to sort
hybridomas cho cells b cells and t
cells and so on
so let's talk a little bit about
lensless imaging this is one of the
interesting aspects of the
bioelectronica system
lensless imaging is where the pods
are flown directly over the cmos imager
and you can see that the reason we call
them pods the o
and the pod stand for oblate meaning
they're not spherical they're squashed
and so what we do is we squash them and
then we flow them over the cmos imager
and it turns out that squashing helps
you
to be able to see the clusters better
so this approach you'll notice it has no
microscope objectives the imager is
directly underneath where the pods are
flowing
this approach offers high resolution so
it offers micron scale resolution over a
wide field of view
it is robust in the sense that it
alleviates a planarity and optical
alignment issues
and it's most importantly that it's
scalable
so you know by not having microscope
objectives and using cmos imagers that
are relatively well
available at this point
we are able to have multiple detectors
multiple sorting elements that are
operating in parallel so
the concept of hypercell is throughput
by parallelization
i'll show you an image here here we have
four
channels in parallel that are all imaged
using just a single cmos imager
uh so essentially it's like having four
flow cytometers
in parallel now you can see in one of
these regions here
a hit is detected by our computer vision
system
a single camera can accommodate four
detection windows and four parallel
channels
and the hyper cell system currently has
four cameras
so that's a total of 16 channels that
are operating
in parallel and
the advantages of doing that is that you
don't have a really high flow rate in
any particular channel the flow rate is
actually
distributed among the channels and so
that gives you lower shear stresses
to improve cell viability and this is
all because the lensless imaging
is a scalable approach where you can you
can replicate or array
your detection windows
uh this slide talks a little bit about
quantifying with computer vision so the
next question is yeah now that we've
we can perform imaging how do we
actually quantify well
we use our computer vision system we've
developed specific algorithms
for identifying both the size of the pod
as well as identifying the contents of
the pod
and both is important because you can
think about normalization type
procedures right
small pods obviously won't have many
beads in them so the clusters in them
would expect be expected to be smaller
so by by using like various types of
normalization
statistical methods we can accommodate
the uh poly dispersed population
and have similar results to a
monodispersed one
so this is an example of low
concentration at the top and high
concentration
at the bottom and you can clearly see
the differences between the two one of
the rules of computer vision is that
if you can visually see the differences
between
two types of populations and computer
vision
and various types of statistical or
machine learning methods can be used to
tell the difference between them
just so just to highlight again this is
what a typical uh
you know a hit might look like
uh you can see that within this
microscope image you can see this the
signal from the secreted antibody which
is a cluster of beads
and notice that the beads are actually
attached to
the the cell itself this is this can
often be the case of the cell if some of
the
biomarkers are being secreted to the
external environment and some of them
are actually
still on the cell membrane this can also
be
detected in our computer vision system
the pentagram here is our detection
window
where the computer vision is applied and
uh based on what
the computer vision sees within this
pentagram a sorting decision is made and
it gets directed to the hit collect
outlet or the waste collect using our
you know proprietary electrofluidic
sorting system
uh this technology we're quite happy
that
last year 2020 the society of laboratory
automation and screening
awarded hypercell the best new
technology product award
and then finally there's also the
question of you know how much throughput
can you really get
this slide sort of alludes to that here
we use rapid computer vision algorithm
you'll see this
oh i'm sorry like let me let me just
save the video i'll play it again
okay so in this video you can see what's
happening
is that the computer vision algorithms
are analyzing
not only the pods the volume and
velocity and the shape of the pods but
also what is inside the pods
the size and the darkness of the
clusters that are formed
and there are certain methods that we
can use to determine cell counts as well
so um the question then becomes about
you know
how fast can computer vision analyze
we've we've shown that by
optimizing your algorithms by using
parallelization methods
we can analyze more than 500 000 pods
in in less than 15 minutes which comes
out to throughputs of
um you know more than a thousand pots
per second so
you know traditional flow cytometers are
working actually in the same range
the difference is is that a single
channel flow cytometer is all going
through a single channel so the detector
has to operate very rapidly
but if you have multiple detectors
operating parallel they don't have to
have the same throughput requirements
number one and number two again as i
mentioned earlier
there there's less shear stress when you
have multiple channels operating in
parallel
now the computer vision itself extracts
multiple parameters up to 20 different
parameters using computer vision
and those parameters offer a great deal
of flexibility
in choosing um in in basically defining
the thresholds for your sorting
um so at bioelectronica we like to say
that there's
that we can software define a new
a new assay so by choosing you know some
bead-based reagents and software
defining our thresholds
you can quickly adapt to different cell
types different antibody types and so on
so just to summarize some of the key
innovations here
with the hypercell system so the
hypercell uses novel bead-based
detection reagents which are adaptable
to a variety of
polyclonal monoclonal antibodies they're
compatible with lensless imaging and
don't require fluorescence
so we've shown that we can use computer
vision to trigger the sorting
of single cells based on their secretion
profiles in concert with
the bead-based detection reagents so
this provides like
softer programmable sorting thresholds
we use electrofluidic chips from the pcb
industry the electronic supply chain
which allows us to integrate flow
control sorting and control electronics
and we use poly disperse rather than
monitor mono disperse
dispersions this allows for high
throughputs and allows users
to use standard laboratory vortexers
instead of the
the microfluidic droplet generators
and then finally and most importantly is
this concept of throughput by
parallelization all these components are
designed with
with this concept in mind so that we can
have multiple detection windows multiple
sorting elements operating in parallel
so that each sorting element doesn't
experience
too much flow rate or too much shear
stress which would
impact cell viability so this approach
helps us to improve cell
viability which is which is great for
when you're working with sensitive cell
types for example like d cells
so to summarize some of the learning
objectives again i hope uh hope at this
point that you've
understood a little bit more about the
role of single cell screening in
antibody discovery
some of the concepts of single cell
partitioning some of the methods that
have been used for single cell screening
and how
the hyper cell system compares to those
and and just some of the concepts that
are used in our system so clustering
lensless imaging computer vision working
together
to perform uh single cell antibody
secretions
based sorting so with that i'd like to
thank you
uh for your attention and interest in
the hypercell system and i'd also like
to thank the many members of the
bioelectronica team
just a small sampling are shown in this
picture bioelectronic is
based out of reno nevada which is
actually quite a beautiful place
if you've never had a chance to visit we
welcome you
so thanks again and thanks again to lab
roots for the opportunity
to present to you today